very important for dallas kykel and this
is 12th start of the year looking for
his fifth win
the area four and a half he's got to
keep it down tonight he's got to throw
ground balls the wind is blowing very
briskly out to left center field
there's the key match-ups no mar mazar
who's not in the lineup is not going to
match up with him well from the bench
miguel cabrera is it a home run against
him jonathan scope also has it's robbie
grossman the switch hitting right
fielder tonight
and this is right back to the mound
dallas kykel does such a great job on
the mound fielding his position robbie
grossman probably should try somebody
else because dallas has multiple gold
gloves only three current pitchers have
that he is one of them
two balls and two strikes
on the detroit third baseman
that's certainly strike three
and candelario knew it two down he
started walking seemingly as that ball
hit the glove it's a glove on yazmati he
frames it nicely and then he walks on
back here is cabrera the future hall of
famer
up the middle but playable tim will get
over to the bag and leap across to end
the inning madrigal to anderson running
the two-man weave no score after a half
inning and spencer turnbull toes the
rubber for the ninth time this season uh
in his 46 innings of work he's only
allowed dare i say it one home run now
we talked about it last night chicago a
place where it warms up ball starts
flying so this would be a challenge for
him he's looking to do something
different to chicago here's adam eat
batting second again for chicago eaton
strikes out second out here in the first
it seems like whenever spencer can get
to this slider he has a put away pitch
the depth of that breaking ball right
there that's unhittable really because
it's down at the bottom of the zone
almost shoe top part of the zone two
away for johan monkatta here's the 02
from turnbull
on the ground left side for candelario
that is a 10 pitch first inning for
spencer turnbull now grand all with two
outs hitting 137 he homered last night
tags this ball left field he has done it
again
yes goes yard and it's one nothing socks
he is feeling better huh the legs are
good and if the legs are good he'll hit
home runs and what he said was when the
legs are good he can hit the ball in the
air when he hits the ball in the air
he's strong enough to take it out
this was a great sign that he hit it to
left field so the sox on top one to
nothing board home run replay only the
second home run turnbull has given up
all year it shows you how good that
sinker has been it also shows you how
good yasmani feels feels a lot better
right now well he's got a history of
showing up and putting balls in seats so
it's not surprising derrick hill will
bat 1-0
to short tim for nick
nick for jose
and he got him
what a great tag by jose because that
was
not a good throw by nick
looked like a tailor made too i don't
know if the ball slips out of nick's
hands but they want to see and if they
can take a look at it again hill's got
very good speed that is a bad throw
looked like he got him on the back i
would say yes he did that's one of those
you hope the tigers will use their
challenge yeah right between the five
and four four and a half even though it
went 6-4 6-4-3 and jose with a nice tag
jonathan scott
scope drills one to left field that's
going to get by lamb all the way up to
the wall grossman's going to hustle home
jonathan scopes got himself an rbi
double and the tigers have evened it at
one mr scope is remaining hot here he
gets a pitch that he's able to handle
and drives it to the gap in left center
field it's a breaking ball but it was a
mistake pitch and look at the timing of
scope here
just barrels this ball as soon as it's
hit with two outs robbie's on the go
and he's motoring around second no play
for material at the plate there's a good
example of robbie putting his head down
he knows what he's supposed to do here
he's supposed to score from first on a
double
and he does so easily nice answer for
the tigers turnbull had a talk with the
trainer and he's going to have to leave
the ball game trainer was grabbing his
elbow so maybe that's what he was
talking about one down for t.a all it
takes is one hit to open the spigot
hard hit pass to dive short tim's on his
way to second two runs are home it's
three to one jim going right back up the
middle drives home a pair he's got 20
for the year he's three for four with
the bases loaded this year he got his
low fastball looking for more infield in
for the tigers 3-1 socks
on the ground to second base throw
coming home and it is late and it gets
away
la oreo mantas to the plate two are in
adam to second base it's not exactly the
running of the bulls but it's a bad day
for funkhouser one and two to abraju
abreu to shortstop this is short for
castro and oh that's a grenade that gets
away
eaton scores and the sox have run number
six scope doesn't make the play but it's
a bad throw and it's going to go e4 so
this is interesting they have e2 e3 e4
and it's
not a good throw
it'll be jonathan scope the 1-2 hammered
to left that ball is out of here a solo
homer to lead off the sixth and jonathan
scopes big night continues well there's
one guy that seems to be
absolutely dialed in we saw it last year
for quite some time jonathan scope again
sits on a pitch and doesn't miss it but
leo renounced one strike on him
to third candelario what a good play
that was on a rocket so leary was
baiting him you know thinking well look
i got a bad arm so maybe he'll move off
the line a little bit the old bad arm
liner
that was
that was a rocket nice play by
candelaria 102 off the bat and it went
exactly 102 feet one down for madrigal
nick madrigal gives it a ride left
center field long run for hill at the
track it is out of here
how lively is the ballpark tonight 402
feet off the bat of nick maddego for his
second home run long run for hill but
the fence interrupted his pursuit big at
bat here in the 7.02 to grossman drives
one to right field adam eaton's got it
zach short tags grossman with a
sacrifice fly to get the tigers to
within four jonathan scope has had a
great evening the one-two
deep left field that ball is gone
another homer for jonathan scope his
massive night continues and the tigers
have made it very uncomfortable for the
white sox here in the seventh they're
within one they're a cost at the play
now the 2-1
drives did he get a deep left center
field that ball is gone
the tigers have stunned the white sox
with a massive inning here in the
seventh they've taken the lead
unbelievable he's got to find a bit of a
happy medium
to where he's not so defensive just
trying to
bunt the ball with the swing basically
mercedes hits it high to center field
pretty well hit hill is back though and
he's there to make the catch aubrey
who's gonna tag he's on his way to
second base the throw is in time to
braves out
jose was trying for second base and he's
thrown out by hill in center
hill just looked at good room as if to
say i don't know
i don't know why he tested me but abreu
thought he might catch him napping and
two down so grandall one and one
he hits the ball high in the air right
center new ball game yes again
his second of the night third in two
days
told us the legs were feeling good he
told us that
the home runs were coming all he had to
do was elevate first multi-hit game
since april 5th he's been on base all
four times a couple of home runs he's
got nine for the year and suddenly 21
driven in here's a backdoor slider it
went out the front door illustrious
career
[Applause]
cabrera gives it a ride left center
field billy is there
now badou chased back to first
billy hamilton just made an exceptional
play
in the alley and left center
and he deserves
this
crowd's love which he is getting right
now see if 21 000 can activate the
yerminator a one-o to mercedes
that is a game winner he was over his
last 25 and nobody cares anymore
nine eight your final